هكذا كانت الصوره بمكب النفايات بطريق
الميناء بمدينه صفاقس السنه لهب وسحوب
دخان يتواصل انبعاثها لليوم الرابع على
التوالي
قوات الدفاع المدني تواصل هي ايضا جهودها
لاخماد الحريق ولكن هذه المره وفق خطه
جديده
وكل مسؤول عليها
الشاحنات
ان شاء الله نتمنى ان شاء الله اليوم موعد
في الوقت الذي تواصل فيه فرقوا الدفاع
المدني مكافحه الحريق الذي شبه النفايات
بمنائه ومنع سحب الدخان من الوصول الى
المدينه تتبادل اطرافها عند الاتهامات حول
مسؤوليه ما يحدث وامكانيه توظيفه سياسيا
قبل الانتخابات القادمه تستقبل مدينه
الصفاقسي يوما اخر وتستقبل معه سحوبا
جديده من الدخان والغازات السامه والروائح
الكريهه مخاوف الاهالي الغاضبين تصاعدت من
عدم امكانيه سيطره عليها في اقرب الايجال
الروائح الكريهه لهذه الكارثه البيئيه
فاحت معها رائحه التجاذبات سياسيه حول
اسبابها ومن يقف وراءها ومن يريد توظيفها
رغم توفر الحلول وفق المختصين في الشان
البيئي
ورؤيه الفساد مؤكده معنا وهذه ثمانيه
اسمها مصلحه مش تضرب
على المواصله في منظومه الرد المولي
العالم لكل رفضها وانتهات معنى الدوله
الحلول الموجوده في ولايه صفاقس ابنائها
ناسا عن معدات هذه وفي ظرف شهرين بحول
الله اول مؤسسه تبدا تشتغل كل الحكومه
تمام الحل جي وتقعد تشد كرسي يعمل الحل ما
تقولش هيك
شعب التونسي هو اللي قاعد يدفع ثمنها يعني
واحنا الفقراء هم اللي قاعدين قسيمه
المجتمع المدني وطنيا